this is definitely a blitz man we are
live live live it's as someone would say
let's go let's go we're gonna have a
competition who gets the most caps all
right let's go go for it okay i'm easily
what notorious this looks like a really
good blitz man i don't know why doesn't
because it's quite narrow what's on the
home straight and again yeah equal in
equal in all right I'm going for this
next 100 my duties why did you have to
have that place there why I've got an
IMS [ __ ] on this top top it I'll just
keep getting one shot forget it no I
just threw it and then I died forget
about it you can get back what's all may
got us on the roof oh my god boys it is
on the roof there's a chopper gunner
vista oh my god is a little bomb get the
haley gonna let's go change your let's
go change things lots think night as the
game mommy look at us the joy of places
are covered you get it on
Vince sure bill to get another cup here
we were are they gone off like I'm
pretty sure he's gonna come on i was
sick do it yes pacific us yes I don't
realize the game was glad when I can't
you there I was like taking about time
like pretty short just saw some filled
orders so much really been flooded I'll
make it a million free for looking at
the scoreboard I'm thinking yeah yeah i
still remember i was at all extreme
gaming vs total time I always remember
I'll it I still can picture you cow yeah
ouch movie odd this these are some big
guys very light that was the the jokey
tile we made for our team with the
biggest team in Europe because we were
all quite big guys yeah cowan Tim's
about 64 1920 Stone Age that's me album
was exposed we're just over to the lake
so you fit all right yeah I'm kind of
just picking up four pieces school but
very very even although i don't know
that's keep running in my eye they don't
have anyone on the team he's 21 and
three leaving a realistic school
oh my days a massacre Oh 7p this is a
jersey are we drop me off that's it